welcome back so i'm really excited about a
brand new lecture series on vector calculus
and how we use vector calculus to derive and solve
partial differential equations so this is one of
my absolute favorite fields of all of mathematics
is dynamical systems and partial differential
equations and essentially these partial
differential equations express conservation laws
so all partial differential equations from
physics essentially express some conservation laws
like mass momentum energy so let's say mass
momentum momentum and energy okay so for example
uh momentum conservation and a fluid navy
or stokes equations mass conservation is
the continuity equation and so on and so
forth so uh we're going to essentially learn
how vector calculus is the language of partial
differential equations okay so vector calculus and
when i say vector calculus i mean things like uh
you know the gradient the divergence and the curl
are essentially the language of how we describe
these conservation laws so this is the language
for pdes and usually these are taught kind
of separately when i was learning you know
vector calculus was an interesting thing that was
independent you know you solved a bunch of surface
integrals and volume integrals they didn't really
tell you why you were doing that but it turns out
that the reason you want to learn vector calculus
is because that is how you translate the world the
physical laws of the world into differential
equations that you can solve and analyze
on pencil and paper on a computer and this
is where you build all of the intuition for
how these things work okay so i think you know
this is a pretty interesting perspective this
is kind of a holistic view of not just pdes but
pdes and vector calculus and so right now i'm
just going to give you a very high level view
of some of the things we're going to talk about
so we're going to talk about the intuition for
div grad and curl these vector calculus operations
things like stokes's theorem and
gauss's theorem that allow you to
really do some of these manipulations you
need to write these conservation laws down
as partial differential equations and then
we're going to start deriving from scratch
the heat equation laplace's equation uh mass
continuity navy or stokes and we're going to make
very clear what the assumptions along the way are
are there shock waves is there some kind of laser
you know pumping energy into my system all of
this uh we can kind of express in the language
of vector calculus and i'm super excited to
walk you through this uh and so in general
we think about a kind of a vector field so
um maybe i'll just start with a good example
that i like which is uh i always think about
fluid flows so let's think about a fluid flow
in the gulf of mexico and this is a really
terrible gulf of mexico maybe i'm from here
cuba is somewhere not on this map and we
assume that there is some literally a vector
field there is a fluid velocity field at every
point in space and realistically it's probably
changing in time okay so there is some vector
field we're going to call this u of x and t
and when i write it this way usually i'm going
to put an under bar or an over arrow when i mean
a vector okay and so literally what i mean by
this is that this is a two-dimensional vector
consisting of the let's say i take one of
these it has so this is vector u it has a u
component and a v component a component in the
x direction and a component in the y direction
so this is u of x and y comma t
and little v of x and y comma t
and this little u is different than
this bold u this bold u is a vector
of the x component and the y component of the
velocity so this is my fluid velocity field
and it is the solution of a partial differential
equation okay there is some partial differential
equation that represents mass momentum and energy
conservation namely the navier-stokes equations
and i would have to solve that pde to get this
vector field okay so this is a vector field
and i call it a vector field because literally
it's a field of vectors at every point x and
y and at every instant in time there is a vector
at that location and it's like a field of vectors
like if you look at a wheat field blowing in the
wind it shows you the vector field of the wind
and that's what this is here
okay and so this vector field
is the solution of a partial differential
equation so in this case maybe i have some pde
which is partial u partial t so this
vector field u and this is bold u
it's changing in time and its rate of
change in time at every point in space
is going to be given by some generically
nonlinear function of that vector field okay
good and this might have other partial derivatives
with respect to space it might have non-linear
product terms and things like that will derive all
of these from scratch in particular you know these
these equations here and importantly if this is a
real flow in the gulf of mexico you know the flow
field changes in time also so i'm going to say
and not not just the flow field changes in time
the dynamics change in time because it's heated
differently in the summer than in the winter so
there might also be some time dynamics this might
be a function of the state and the time and this
is a very general framework i can i can derive
many different vector and scalar fields that are
the solution the partial differential equations
for example the temperature in a metal plate if
i hit it with a blow torch in the middle of
that plate maybe i'll draw that so if i have
some metal plate here and
i hit it with a blow torch
so i have some kind of you know hot pattern
here and then it gets cooler and cooler out here
and i want to solve for that temperature
distribution um let's call that big t
as a function of x and y and time that is again
the solution of a partial differential equation in
particular this one is pretty easy to write it's
partial t with respect to time is equal to some
positive constant alpha squared times the
partial squared in x plus the partial squared n y
which i'm going to very compactly represent
using my vector notation as the laplacian
of the temperature which is partial squared
t partial x squared plus partial squared t
partial y squared okay so again i can derive we're
going to derive this heat equation from scratch
to satisfy this physics here okay namely youknow kind of conservation of heat energy in thisuh in this plate good so
We're going to showyou how to derive partial differential equationsby encoding these conservation laws
using thelanguage of vector calculus and we'll be able todescribe tons of physics phenomena
from heatdistributions to how an airplane wing works andgenerates lift
to how a flow field evolves inthe Gulf of Mexico, or in some other fluid flowenvironment.
So really excitingstuff here. And I want to point out also, if I have a vector field some solution of a partialdifferential equation, "u",
I can also think about the induced ordinary differential equation, of if I dropped a particle in this flow field
so imagine that I'm lost at sea... so this is me attime 0... I'm "x_0" and that means x at time 0, y attime 0.
And what we're going to do is we're goingto be able to solve for the future trajectory of that point by integrating that particle
through this vector field; so this vector field, this flow field, is the solution of my partialdifferential equation by Navier-Stokes equations
but it also induces a new dynamical system... so if I
drop a particle, then that particle sees this dynamical
system so I could also say -- let me see how I wantto write this -- I want to say dx/dt, and again
this is my bold x is equal to u(x,t) so
this u is a dynamical system for how a particle x
will float through the Gulf of Mexico... maybe this
is a little oil spill and I want to track that
oil spill and see where it goes. There's lots of
tools for propagating a little Gaussian
through this dynamical system. That's something I
might want to do on a computer to predict where
the oil spill is going to go or maybe someone got
lost at sea off the coastline and swept away and
i've got four hours to rescue them -- where shouldI search to find those people?
These are real problems that engineers are working on today based
on the numerical solution of these problems.
Which is extremely cool -- I mean I just love how many
applications and it's tied to all of my favorite
things in dynamical systems. At the end of the day
these PDEs set up dynamical systems for the fluid
flow evolution and the fluid flow itself sets up
a dynamical system for how particles move through
the fluid flow good and we could do things like
integrate that particle through and find x at timet.
Okay and this might be you know little x at time
t and little y at time t and i could integrate
numerically the position of this
particle through that vector field
okay um what else do i want to show you maybe i'll
give you just a very very quick example of what
grad and div and curl are in these examples here
okay so if i have a local patch of my flow field
where things are locally on average
moving away kind of diverging this
is a location that has a positive divergence
so the div of u is going to be greater than
0 at this point and we would say like div is
positive this has a this has a positive divergence
and so the divergence i'll walk you through all
of these in great detail and show you exactly
how this works but in some sense the divergence
measures locally how much stuff is kind of flowing
away from that point or sucking into or converging
into that point so like your sink is literally a
place where the divergence is less than zero okay
and when you like hit the faucet and it hits the
metal and it's causing the flow to go out that's
a place where the divergence is greater than zero
similarly maybe it's hurricane season and
i've got a region over here where my flow
is going in a big you know big cyclone it's coming
in to the gulf this would be an area where i
would have a positive curl okay and so the curl
would be greater than zero and that's given by
this kind of del cross and i'll show you how these
dots and crosses work this this grad operator is
literally a vector of partial derivatives and
i can take its dot product with u and v or its
cross product with this uv velocity field uh
good and of course i hope it's obvious that in
three dimensions this u would have a u v and
a w component for the x y and z components of
the velocity field and this can generalize to 10
dimensions or a million dimensions you can have
the heat equation in 5d there's nothing wrong
with that it's just this equation here okay
The last one I haven't shown you is the gradient--
and I really like the gradient because the
gradient takes a scalar field, like a temperaturedistribution, this is just a scalar at every point
and it returns a vector field. So if I compute thegradient of my temperature it will essentially...
if I look at the gradient of my temperature at thispoint here, it will tell me in what direction is
the temperature locally increasing the fastest.
So it'll essentially establish a vector field
of where the temperature is increasing
the fastest. So grad of T is a vector
at every point in x and y that says: climb
this way if you want to get hotter faster
if you want to go to the hot spot as
fast as possible follow the gradient direction.
This is the "grad" and this is a huge deal in
modern computer optimizations and machine learning
we do gradient descent or gradient searches to
find the maximum value of a cost function or
the minimum value of a loss function and we use
stochastic gradient descent to train all of our
machine learning algorithms... not all, but many of
our machine learning algorithms. So again these
gradients extend to million dimensional spaces
where we train models for machine learning and
it all comes back to this kind of physical
intuition of you know partial differential
equations and conservation laws... vector calculus.
I'm super excited to walk you through this
I'm going to start simple -- we're going to start
with kind of what these vector calculus terms mean--
we're going to start learning things like
Gauss's theorem and Stokes's theorem like
Gauss's divergence theorem... we're going
to use those to encode these physical
ideas of conservation of mass, momentum, and energy
and derive our partial differential equations
for real physical systems... things like Navier-Stokes, or the heat equation, or mass continuity.
This is all coming up really excited to walk youthrough this.
This is how i wish i had learnedvector calculus and PDEs.
So please stay tuned and keep watching for more.
Thank you